hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
what i want to talk about now is this
weird word that he calls the full maze
all right
that's a kind of law and this is in in
article
6 of question 91
whether there's a law in the full mates
of sin and
why why do we have this weird word
because nobody's quite sure
how to translate it well frankly and i
don't know how to translate it well to
make
sense and we'll just call it that and
it's basically something like
um for us
following our our pure animality
detached from reason when reason has
become defective
and so he says when he's considering
this
um
everything participates in the eternal
law
even the instincts that animals have
participate in the eternal life
so he says under the divine login
various creatures have various natural
inclinations
so what is as it were a law for one is
against the law
for another and he uses the example of a
dog
and a sheep or other meat animal and he
talked about fierceness
forget little lab dogs or stuff like
that most dogs are great fears right
i usually a little bit earlier take a
stick
poke a dog with it they'll bite that
stick won't they
now go ahead and do that to a sheep and
you won't get quite the same reaction
run away it's got different sets of
instincts doesn't it
and each animal has built into it
a set of basic instincts that make it
what it is that produce the behavior
that's characteristic of it
so you know think about a lion what are
what are some of the typical lion
behaviors
that you'd associate with eating other
impacts
yeah i mean lions are not vegetarians
you can try to make them vegetarians but
it's not going to work because they're
designed they're designed to do that
um let's say we take it you know her her
laborious animal
like a horse um can you feed a horse
meat
i suppose you could but you know you'd
screw up the horse as a result
but there are legendary things you know
i don't think there's
any basis to this whatsoever there are
some legends about people feeding horses
meat how do lions behave
how do they get their knee yeah
they are i mean go go and start messing
with a lion
and the horse will probably take off
i mean the horse knows you're a predator
right right off the bat
this is one of the things they teach in
horse training to be aware of the fact
that the horse
by looking at you you know you've got
eyes in the front of your head
that means you're a predator you're
coming towards it you're
big and tall you're a predator
you know it'll take off that's a natural
instinct
about a lion approach a lion in the wild
probably not a good idea thank you
violence territory
yeah well they they are territorial
horses actually
can sometimes have territorial things um
how do lions live together
yeah right in a pride a pack is sort of
a general
it's okay it's a gentleman we have all
sorts of crazy things like
crows or murderer and
wolves dogs are in packs i guess cats
are all in prides maybe if you have a
whole bunch of house cats together
i don't know
flock of sheep right um
do you guys know how it works in the
lion world it's actually kind of brutal
you know there's there's like one top
lion
the the male lion and then there may be
a few younger ones
with him fairly rare and then there's
the females
who actually does also hunting phoenix
yeah
and then there's all these cups and the
thing of the males is basically like
being tanks you know like the armored
vehicles you know the guns on them
um kind of unwieldy they're not doing a
lot of the hunting because they're so
massive
they don't they can't chase things down
quite as quite as well
as the females can but the males are
really good at fighting
one kind of thing in particular you know
what it is
what's that now lions when they put
lions and tigers together
tigers are a lot bigger than lions and
they rip them pretty badly
but luckily they don't occupy the same
territory yeah each other
other male lions because the the rogue
males
who come in and they want to take over
the pride
and if they succeed one thing that
they're going to do is kill every one of
the cubs
it's just part of their nature that you
know part of reproduction and
and you know passing on their their
genetic heritage
and the females will often you know if
the
the rogue male comes in and defeats the
main male
he'll often get killed in the process
sometimes the females will be killed in
the process defending the cops
they can be pretty bloody actually lions
are like us
they're one of the um animals that
engages in the most
inter-spe intra-species predation
where it's lions killing lions um
another
animal that is sort of up there with us
like that
believe it or not chimpanzees
chimpanzees are so aggressive towards
other chimpanzees
that they will actually make strategic
decisions to like go
and hunt down another group of
chimpanzees and wipe them up
they're so much like us we
we are unique really in that respect not
not everything that's unique about us is
necessarily good
right it's part of why the natural law
is so important to keep those sort of
things in check
now so animals all have their own their
own particular natures and they all have
their
sort of law and thomas says
the law of man which by the divine
ordinance is a latitude
according to his proper natural
condition is that he should act in
accordance with reason
that's what it is to follow natural law
to use the faculty of reason that's been
given to us
what happens if we don't use the faculty
of reason
well we are animals we do still remain
animal we still have the same sort of
drives that other animals
do and so he says
this very inclination of sensuality what
do you mean since by sensuality is our
animal nature you know what what are the
things that we
have basic drives towards that we desire
you know
we want food we want shelter
we want security we want sex
we want power
now we start to get more distinctively
human things we want to be
on top we want to win we want to
attack things that make us afraid or run
away from them
and if if reason isn't calling the shots
then we revert to our animal nature but
our animal nature isn't
really like the other animals in some
respects we're wars
when we become just mere animals we're
way worse than any mary animal
because the animals got you know its own
sort of regulatory system
it's it's nature that was built into it
i mean sometimes they'll obstruct their
territories you know
rabbits go to australia and eat too much
of the grass and then you have a rabbit
problem
because there weren't rabbits there
before then you find something else that
preys on them and then they get brought
back into check
what about us if we don't control
our desires we're much more dangerous
than any other
animal not just to the other animals but
to each other
we can think of all sorts of ways to
hurt each other that animals never
devise
sometimes we actually like look at the
other animals we're like
uh that's not a bad idea to hurt
somebody that way
you know that's what you know all
sorts of ways in which we go wrong when
we don't follow the natural law
then we're stuck with these sort of
disordered desires that
we have within us ourselves yeah so this
bonus
like kind of once you let your animal
nature take over you you start using
reason to fulfill those animal desires
rather than that's another good
good point when we talked about this
with plato right you can have your
appetites
and you have reason there's a third part
we'll leave that out of the process
right
and when you're properly functioning
reason is calling the shots and it's
telling the appetites
hey you get to indulge yourself but only
this much because
i want this this and this and this and
this and
if the appetites are calling the shots
this is again why we're so dangerous
when our appetites are calling the shots
we don't stop the way other animals
would
you know dogs don't actually go into
murderous rages and then hunt down
the families of other dogs who cross
them
human beings do well sometimes they're
not even in a murderous rage sometimes
it's just business you know gotta
eliminate the competition
criminal enterprises do that sort of
thing so yeah
reason can become subordinated in the
human being to
our basic desires and i want to i want
to hit on why thomas thinks sometimes we
can go wrong
with this sort of thing uh he talks
about this a little bit later on in
question
94 where he's talking about the natural
law
and he's dealing with questions like is
the natural law always working
inside of us you know if we've got these
inclinations
how do we actually go back
how is it that we end up you know
lapsing into this sort of thing
and he says um when it comes to the
practical reason
how we figure out what we like to do
what's the good thing what what our
course of action are today
we don't always know what we want to do
sometimes our practical reason
can be defective it can they cannot
actually
lead us to what it's supposed to do what
can
actually screw us up with these sort of
things
he says
there can be certain obstacles that
arise
some of these could be in terms of
knowledge
so what keeps you from knowing what what
the good
is he says well your reason could be
perverted by
passion by by the emotional part of the
world
so again think of the person who's who's
got a vicious disposition with respect
to anger
and now they're off the handle somebody
somebody
made them angry you better look out for
them right
because the natural law is in them
but they're not listening to it are they
they're listening instead to what it is
that their their emotions are telling
them
can ignore reason because of grief too
or just because of
you know the desire for pleasure or uh
a number of other things um
an evil habit what are what are evil
habits those are the vices
so if you are in temperate if you
characteristically are self-indulgent
you're
always you know seeking to have your
your sensual desires satisfied
think about some of the things that
would lead you to
to do in contrary to the natural law
you know would you stop with seconds or
thirds
if it's with respect to food even though
the natural lot probably tell you hey
that's enough food for you leave
something for everybody else
no it's a bad habit or an evil
disposition
of nature that means like you know there
are cases where somebody's
screwed up we talked about addiction as
an example of that before
another thing that thomas talks about as
well is
he talks about the natural law being
able to be blotted out from the human
heart
sort of in a way of being made inactive
by vicious customs so if you grow up in
a society
where people are for the most part
screwed up you're going to have a much
harder time
actually listening to the natural law
so he uses this example we don't know
that it was actually true
but the ancient romans thought that this
was the case
that the ancient germans thought that
theft was okay
so long as you got away with it it was
good it's fine
and everybody else pretty much thought
it was a bad idea the natural losses
don't steal other people's property
right well let's assume that that was
actually the case
that you have a society in which theft
is considered okay
so long as you get away with it or so
long as you can you know
fight off the person that you're you're
stealing things from
how would you then look at those sort of
matters
would you think to yourself
well i know that this is what my society
is teaching me
but i know that that's not the right way
kind of tough to do that wouldn't it if
everybody else around you is practicing
this and you're seeing examples of it
all the time
um it might be hard to actually listen
to the natural law
yeah is that where divine law comes in
place though i guess
yeah it could be very useful for that
for that reason okay
you know think about some some other
examples
um some more
seemingly innocuous examples
americans are workaholics compared to
other
societies we
we tend to put in a lot more hours and
put up with a lot
more sacrifices
than to do other people there's some
good things about that aren't there
i mean we're also pretty productive and
we generate a lot of
wealth and stuff in the process
but do people make bad decisions
when they're balancing work against
other goods
you see people doing that and where do
they make those sort of bad decisions
what are some of the other goods they
trade off against that
yeah family life that's probably the
biggest one
and family life has to do with
obligations that you actually have to
other people
you know if you marry somebody and you
make some kids with them that's not a
morally neutral thing
for somebody like thomas aquinas you're
actually incurring some pretty important
obligations
as a matter of fact that's part of the
natural laws we're going to see in just
a minute
so if you're taking work which is a good
thing
again i don't want to say you know
thomas is saying be lazy or you know
let's all be a bunch of condiments or
anything like that
and cool everything he thinks that work
is a good thing
but it ought to be balanced against
these other very important goods
and the natural law can tell you that
now if you belong to a society
which is constantly telling you you are
your job
how how easy is it for you to say no
no my spouse needs me to be home
um i have to watch the kids i need to
spend some more time with my kids
is it easy to do that that is an
inclination
but following that inclination is pretty
tough
if you grow up in a household where
your parents didn't make the time
for your activities or came home so
burnt out from work that they couldn't
take any interest
in your activities is it going to be
harder for you to do that for your kids
it will be a bit harder yeah i mean not
insurmountable right
and sometimes we actually have the
counter reaction you say
this is awful i'm not going to be like
that i'm not going to force that on my
kids
that's easy to say though because
oftentimes
you know we have an intention following
through on it
is a different manner we often do end up
looking an awful lot like our parents
so there are some things that could end
up you might say
deactivating or suspending the natural
law making it so that it can't
get the traction that it needs it can't
actually
steer us in ways that we want it to
and that you know if we're not following
this
we're going to be following this because
this is part of us as well
our fallen nature